peu
baa
on
oh
c'est de noël un roman de gabriel vers
aldi les espions de bonne volonté comme
l'indiquent le titre il s'agit d'un
roman d'espionnage
mais peut-être est-ce plus encore un
roman sur l'espionnage
il y a beaucoup de réseaux les réseaux
sont très à la mode en ce moment où le
savez il ya beaucoup de réseaux dans ce
livre mais il n'y en a particulièrement
original c'est un réseau de savants
c'est une sorte d'anti réseau même
pourrait-on dire les moyennes et ali en
tout cas ça serait plutôt la prise de
conscience par des scientifiques que les
protestations morale ne suffisent pas
dans le cas de l'utilisation à des fins
qu'il n'approuve pas de leur découverte
et la décision -peut-être forme
d'ailleurs de passer à l'action directe
disons qu'au début du roman il y à un
meurtre dans les romans d'espionnage les
choses commencent enfin la construction
de ce livre puisque le fait même
d'écrire est une joie n'est ce pas qui
est un peu oublié maintenant et que
j'évolue dans ce livre limitée dumas
imiter tous les grands conteurs français
consiste à montrer un meurtre sur le
théâtre et ensuite à passer directement
dans les coulisses et ses coulisses ce
sont celles de la police de l'espionnage
et des autres forces industrielles
scientifiques politiques humaines
également qui se partageront ils ont
pour fixer les idées que ce réseau le
savant poursuivre un but ce but c'est
quoi exactement
rêver ce but celui d'une résistance il
ya une très vieille idée dans les livres
d'aventurés d'espionnage et celle du
savant fou c'est à dire de l'homme qui
grâce à une découverte technique va
servir le monde
cette idée du savant fou rend les
scientifiques furieux car un
scientifique qu'est ce que c'est c'est
un homme qui avant tout veut comprendre
l'univers qui n'a pas absolument pas
envie de contrôler le monde et de faire
ce travail qui l'empoisonnent et
allemand ce paquet et qui consiste à
administrer à donner des ordres à
gouverner le savent on ne veut pas être
maître du monde il veut comprendre le
monde
bientôt il ya eu une longue époque où il
a joué à l'apprenti sorcier c'est à dire
qu'ils lançaient dans le monde sans
savoir sans évaluer les conséquences
sans savoir
ce qu'il lançait produirait comme remous
découverte terrifiante de plus en plus
et ceci ce n'est pas du roman c'est une
réalité concrète une réalité quotidienne
une réalité contemporaine
les savants vols contrôlés ce qu'il
lance dans le monde
et alors ce roman est le récit est la
description d'une sorte de conspiration
de savants pour faire justement cette
sorte d'ajouter si l'on peut dire
l'utilisation de contrôle de
l'utilisation de leurs découvertes à la
découverte elle même ils ont qu'il ya à
l'origine de cette histoire
un savant qui symbolise peut être
aujourd'hui tous les savants moderne
c'est einstein et un nouveau personnage
évoquant la fameuse lettre que einstein
écrit vite au président roosevelt et qui
déclenche
historiquement la fabrication de la
bombe atomique par les américains 2 un
nouveau personnage parlant d'einstein à
cette époque dit fallait-il flinguer
einstein ainsi que le problème est posée
et la réponse c'est non il ya une autre
solution
la réponse était sympa à l'époque
c'était en 1939
einstein qui depuis 30 ans savait que
l'on pouvait tirer une arme bombes
atomiques de ces travaux l'avaient
toujours nié en 1939 il a pris la grave
résolution d'aller dire à roosevelt
on peut faire une arme avec ma
découverte je sais que certains
allemands la prépare allons-y et la
théorie de ce réseau de scientifiques
qui joue je crois assez souvent aux
apprentis sorciers de la politique pour
ne pas jouer aux apprentis sorciers de
la science de l'action donc de ce réseau
consiste à faire que les savants la
douzaine la quinzaine la vingtaine de
très grands créateurs dans chaque
domaine se connaissent et n'ai pas peur
des uns des autres et vous avez que ceux
ci une fois encore n'est pas d'un roman
puisque il y as matin des associations
scientifiques mondiales qui ne
respectent aucune frontière qui
n'obéissent à aucune idéologie politique
et qui se rencontrent deux ou trois fois
par an de façon en
ne pas lancer des programmes qui ne
pourraient plus contrôler plutôt
imaginer que si cette association avait
existé à l'époque d'einstein le secret
de la fabrication de la bombe atomique
n'aurait pas transpiré si je puis dire
les choses auraient fait un cours
différent il y à une évolution de la
science comme il ya une évolution de
l'avis attendu que la science est une
des formes n'est ce pas de la vie et
fatalement nous allons vers un certain
nombre de très grandes découvertes et la
découverte de l'énergie nucléaire était
inscrite dans le dynamisme même de
l'évolution cela dit les circonstances
de 1939 la peur la guerre le nazisme et
ainsi de suite
on fait que on adapte d'abord créer une
arme de destruction avant de créer les
techniques au service de l'humanité et
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à rétablir cet
équilibre
vous dites que ce réseau de savants non
pas tel qu'il existe dans votre livre
qui est un roman bien sûr mais que
l'origine réelle ce réseau le savant
existe vous citez des réunions au site
et un groupe de savants actuelle vous
appelez le groupe de pogo chaïb alors ce
site ce n'est pas du roman d'espacé
vraiment d'histoire il y a maintenant
une dizaine d'années c'est-à-dire après
la mort de staline quand il ya débat
réalisations du régime soviétique
les savants de l'est et de l'ouest on
puisse rencontrer à genève
et là au cours d'une conférence officie
ces conférences officielles les
conférences sur l'énergie atomique
justement cette confrontation qui a été
une très grande date dans l'histoire de
la science en général et aux mécènes
canadien a réuni dans une petite donné
ils ont pu dire à une sorte de
conférence le nom de sa petite ville
natale au canada pour gouache et depuis
six avants se rend compte périodiquement
la dernière conférence a eu lieu à addis
abeba en janvier de cette année ci et a
réuni des savants de plus de 30 pays
appartenant à absolument toutes les
tendances politiques
de quoi parle-t-on dans ces réunions
selon vous on parle des problèmes les
plus les plus globaux n'est ce pas de
l'évolution de la vie
dans l'évolution politique de des
différents programmes et qu'il faudrait
lancer pour le bien de l'humanité des
grands problèmes que sont la fin la
surpopulation deux problèmes purement
théorique aussi n'est ce pas que sont
les nouvelles images de l'univers et
ainsi de suite
et puis il n'est pas interdit de penser
coeur en coulisses se nouent aussi
d'autres relations qui ont plus tard en
ce qui rompt à développer d'autres
d'autres nations ra il vient à part cela
une correspondance extrêmement intense
entre des savants du monde entier dans
leur spécialité et même hors de leur
spécialité et un petit exemple ce livre
dont il est question est ce qu'ils ont
dans une volonté a été soumis par mon
éditeur américain à au grandes
universités de la côte est des états
unis et le verdict des gens de harvard
uem haïti ainsi de suite a été c'est
naturellement romancée mais c'est ainsi
que ça se passe et peut-être c'est ainsi
que ça se passera bientôt tout à fait il
est à se demander si ce réseau le savant
s'il doit existe un jour n'est pas plus
à craindre qu'à souhaiter car en fait
ces savants dans leurs actions dans le
livre finissent par poser le problème de
la faim et des moyens car pour parvenir
à leur but qui sont humanistes disons
ils finissent par faire de l'action
directe que vous voulez comme vous le
dites et à dire par employé les méthodes
des gens qui veulent combattre
il me dit oui n'est ce pas je crois que
toute action actuellement c'est une
chose très grave ce n'est pas la peña
point de vue scientifique c'est un point
de vue
tom de la rue n'est ce pas aux deux
romanciers qui essaye justement d'être
la conscience de l'homme de la rue et
qu' il y à un processus de doc
stérilisation qui est actuellement
lancée dans le monde et qui intéresse
toutes les formes de l'action et ceci
est extrêmement bas et je ne vois pas
actuellement quelle force scientifico
humaine pourrait essayer de se poser à
se lancer là je crois le plus grave
problème qui nous conforte actuellement
c'est que tout ce temps nous sommes tous
les âges
nous prenons avocat but de connaissances
vocabulaire de bord dit et nous avons de
plus en plus une sorte de tolérance pour
des actes de banditisme qui nous aurait
il ya 50 ans absolument horrifiés enfin
rappelons pour terminer qu'il s'agit
d'un roman d'une fiction pour l'instant
je rappelle le titre de ce roman qu'est
passionnant
à lire le gabriel vers albi chez denoël
les espions de bonne volonté
[Musique]